all right everyone it's almost time to
begin your Journeys in the Pokemon
scarlet and Pokemon Violet games are you
ready you'll get to catch Pokemon
raise them and battle them
as you embark on an adventure where the
familiar charms of the Pokemon series
evolve into a new experience
as a student at an academy in the paldea
region you'll take part in an
independent study program called the
treasure hunt and you'll search this
vast world for a precious Treasure of
your very own but hey at this point you
probably knew all that already right
here's something we hope even you
well-informed viewers will enjoy a sneak
peek at four particular trainers
Journeys in paldea
now let the adventures begin
this trainer is battling a Pokemon
called lechonk Le chunk is a Gourmand
it's proud of its nose which it uses to
sniff out delicious food
[Music]
oh look waxley turrastilized
[Music]
terasterizing is a phenomenon unique to
the paldea region but all Pokemon can do
it
it adds extra punch to moves of the
Pokemon's Terror type
[Music]
what's that over there is that a glowing
Pokemon
it seems to be a Jigglypuff
but why is it shining so bright
better approach it slowly and start a
battle
[Music]
whoa its rasterized looks like this
Jigglypuff has the water type for its
Terror type apparently these sparkly
wild Pokemon will terastalize in battle
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Jigglypuff seems pretty tough
the quaxley strong too
healing enough damage to a wild Terra
Pokemon causes its terasterization to
come undone
now throw a Pokeball
[Music]
nice the wild Jigglypuff was caught
some Pokemon like this Jigglypuff have a
Terra type completely different from
their regular type
any Pokemon is capable of having any of
the 18 different types as its Terra type
what's this quacks leaves out there in
the world charging straight toward that
Lit Leo looks like quaxley battled
litlio on its own and won that's because
the trainer gave quaxley the let's go
command
using let's go will send your lead
Pokemon out onto the field to battle
foreign
gets sent out toward an item it'll go
pick it up just like quaxley here what a
useful command for searching your
surroundings these Pokemon are so
helpful giving their all for their
partner
next the trainer opens his map to see
where he wants to go
you can set a place as your destination
to keep yourself on track as you go then
we can hop Atop The Legendary Pokemon
near ride on and get going
and what have we hear it's a base
belonging to team's star the school
troublemakers Starfall Street one of the
three major stories that will make up
your pal Dayan Adventures will unfold in
bases like this one
time to face team Stars our trainer rang
the bell and barged into the base
that takes some guts but things look bad
there are lots of grunts around and they
keep sending out Pokemon they just won't
quit blocking away we'll need to use
let's go to defeat team Stars Pokemon
[Music]
there we go all the grunts have been
defeated at last but wait is that some
kind of tricked out car
it is
and atop it is Mella the boss of Team
Stars fire crew
she's obviously tough
it's easy to see why she's a boss
time for these trained up Pokemon to
battle
you'll have to wait for your own
adventure to see how a battle like this
plays out
now let's check in on another trainer
how's her Adventure going
aha she's using the TM machine at a
Pokemon Center
a TM machine lets you make your own TMS
also known as technical machines using
materials Pokemon drop when you defeat
or catch them
[Music]
now where will she go next
seems to be a desert-like area under a
blazing sun just looking at it is enough
to make you thirsty oh her Rotom phone
is ringing sounds like Arvin her friend
in the next grade up needs some help
to give Arvin a hand the trainers headed
to a rock face where a Titan looks
this is one of the stops on the path of
Legends a story where you'll seek out
legendary Earths called Urban mystica
there it is a gigantic Titan Pokemon
time to battle
foreign right off the bat there's icy
win the move our trainer taught drifloon
earlier icy wind lowered the Titan
clock's speed step
drifloon terastalized to become a grass
type this is Terra Blast a new move that
changes type to match the user's Terror
type when the user is to rascalized it
ought to be handy for a Pokemon with a
terror type different from its regular
types looks like cloth suddenly got
somewhere else to beat
wait what's our trainer doing now of all
times
looks like she's taking a little break
from adventuring to trade Pokemon with a
friend
and over here her trade partner has
received girafforig
seems like she immediately added
giraffarig to her team and she's gonna
let it run around in the field and train
up for some battles
[Music]
oh could giraphoric be evolving hang on
did its tail become its head or is its
head wearing its tail what an unexpected
Evolution seems like giraffarig has
evolved into for rigorra in the paldea
Region's Pokedex you can see photos of
Pokemon as well as information about
them so you can get to know them even
better
let's check out the town of artisan next
it looks like one big park now that the
trainer's Pokemon have gotten stronger
it seems she's made her way to a gym
she's following Victory Road the story
where you'll conquer all eight gems to
achieve champion ring nimona the
battle-loving trainer who will show you
the ropes is All Fired Up
before you can battle a gym leader
you'll first have to pass the gym test
at their gym better get started right
away
all right that's the gym test passed
time to battle the gym leader
Here Comes gracias the grass type gym
leader with a striking entry
[Music]
whoa pseudowoodo terrestalized and
became a grass type
[Music]
are you gonna be okay Fido
how's our trainer gonna handle this one
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Fido became a flying type that should
give it an edge against this grass type
Sudowoodo no matter who or what you're
up against with some smart teraskolizing
you'll have nothing to fear I can't wait
to see how battles will unfold between
terasterized Pokemon
[Music]
this trainer's heading into a hair salon
to spice things up
wow look at all these options how are
you supposed to choose
[Music]
huh I kind of want to try that hairstyle
too
[Music]
and now to complete the look plenty to
choose from here too I feel like I could
spend all day on this
and while you're trying out all sorts of
styles you can whip out the camera app
and go snap snap snap
looks like this trainer found the
perfect style line up a good shot and
snap now they've updated their profile
picture
looking back on photos you've taken of
Scenic Vistas or memorable moments with
beloved Pokemon is just one more way to
enjoy your adventure
and now it's picnic time with Pokemon
when Pokemon have gotten dirty from a
long journey a nice scrub and shower
gets them all clean
looks like it feels nice too
before having lunch Pokemon can get out
some energy by playing with a ball you
can just tell how much fun they're
having
[Music]
oh wow could this be a Pokemon egg
apparently eggs can sometimes be found
during picnics
[Music]
and now the moment we've been waiting
for sandwich time
this trainer came prepared with plenty
of ingredients they bought in town
it can be tough deciding which sandwich
to make
this one may be a little overstuffed it
might not hold together
[Music]
just gotta put the bread on top and
finish it off with a pick
[Music]
let's see how it tastes
hmm oh looks like it's a hit with
everyone
eating sandwiches can give you benefits
like making certain types of Pokemon
easier to catch or making your Pokemon
game more experience points time for a
group photo with these satisfied Pokemon
where to go next
hey looks like more of our trainer
friends have shown up
all right they're gonna take on a terror
Raid Battle can these trainers work
together to defeat the Terra Pokemon
Before Time Runs Out
their opponent is a chancy that's
taractalized into a ghost type what kind
of fight will the strong sparkling
Chancey put up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it's really powerful these trainers
better stay determined band together and
Strike Back
[Music]
if your Pokemon gets knocked out in a
terror Raid Battle don't worry
it can recover and rejoin The Fray
hang in there stable eye
along with using your Pokemon's moves
you also have the option to support your
allies by cheering it's all about
teamwork
[Music]
watch how the battle's going and decide
how you'll handle the fight and work
with your fellow trainers
almost there keep it up
[Music]
what's up
oh wow that was a beautiful Terror Raid
Battle Victory and with it comes the
chance to catch this Terra Pokemon when
you join forces to win your battles the
bonds between friends and Pokemon shine
even brighter
[Music]
all right that Chansey with a rare Tara
type is now a part of the team
[Music]
so what'd you think
while you are getting a look at these
four trainers Journeys did you spot a
glimmer of something that could become
your personal treasure
encounters with Titan Pokemon face-offs
with Team star taking on gems there's
plenty more to be said about all these
things of course what you just saw was
only a glimpse of the adventures
awaiting you in the paldea region which
Pokemon will you choose who will you
meet what sort of exciting Adventures
will you have it's all up to you your
adventures are right around the corner
may they shine bright
[Music]